en el conflicto que arrasa el este de la
República democrática del Congo los
jefes de estado de África Oriental creen
en las virtudes de la diplomacia las
medias jornada de conversaciones los
presidentes de los países de la
subregión acordaron una solución al
conflicto entre el ejército congolenio y
el grupo Rebelde m23 el ministro de
asuntos exteriores de Angola anunció los
términos de la resolución
hoy en la Cumbre se decidió lo siguiente
el cese de las hostilidades en general y
en particular los ataques del m23 contra
las fuerzas armadas de la República
democrática del Congo a partir del
viernes 25 de noviembre de 2022 a las 18
horas
pero el m-23 no estuvo presente en las
negociaciones y no se siente obligado a
respetar el acuerdo el grupo armado
quiere negociaciones directas con el de
invierno congolenio en goma la capital
de la provincia kibu Norte en el este de
la República democrática del Congo los
habitantes están a las puertas de los
combates y desconfían del acuerdo
algunos incluso han manifestado su
rechazo hacia la comunidad internacional
a la que acusan de apoyar al gobierno
ruandes que a su vez es señalado de
apoyar a los Rebeldes
internacional
dasolasam dijimos que la comunidad
internacional en su conjunto pidan los
jefes de estado ruandeses y ugandeses
que retiren urgentemente sus
combatientes camuflados bajo la etiqueta
m23
uganda por la agresión contra la
República democrática del Congo durante
más de 25 años
Un día después del anuncio del acuerdo
la calma sigue siendo precaria en la
línea del frente a unos kilómetros al
norte de goma otra cuestión que sigue
sin respuesta es la de los desplazados
que huyen de los combates según la más
de 50 mil personas se encuentran en
condiciones extremadamente vulnerables